I'm here for kids and baby boomers and
seniors who don't want to be sick and
miserable for the last 15 to 20 years of
their life like their parents and
grandparents. I am a conservative. A lot
of people say I treat them like dogs,
but they do seem to get better. Have you
ever a personal health challenge you
want to ask about?
If you have a health challenge of a
friend, a loved one, a workmate, or you
want to talk about medical politics or
the home-based business opportunity,
give us a call toll-free 1-888-379-2552.
And that's toll-free 1-888-379-2552.
Well, um small article, I don't know,
about 1/5 of one page in the front
section of the USA Today.
Uh says study, "Statin drug side effects
can be managed." Okay, and it says um
this uh
article occurred or actually came from
Annals of Internal Medicine and it's
about statin drugs.
And it says "Despite their perceived
benefits, some people stop taking them
citing fatigue, muscle pain, confusion,
diabetes."
Um one rare life-threatening side effect
is um
uh
rhabdomyolysis which the muscles break
down the pigment the myoglobin gets into
the liver and kidneys and causes damage
there. A 9-year study of 107,835
patients at Brigham and Women's Hospital
in Boston, 11,124
had discontinued statins on their own
because of side effects.
Okay, uh half started again at the lower
dose or used different statin drug. 90%
were still on it a year later.
This is important news because the
beneficial effects of of statins,
according to the lead author Alexander
Turkin, says there's are potentially
millions of patients who could take the
statins again.
Well, about one in four Americans 45
years of older are taking statin drugs.
Okay, and um the percentage of adults
ages 45 and older whose use of statin
drugs or cholesterol increased from 2%
to 25% in 2008.
And um
uh they're talking about and you have to
go back here and say "No, wait a minute.
Uh what's this confusion thing?" Oh,
that's Alzheimer's disease. Uh what's
this diabetes thing? Oh, type 2
diabetes. Didn't the FDA come out with
warnings that say "Uh-oh, Houston, we
have a problem." cuz some of the side
effects of statin drugs include
Alzheimer's disease and type 2 diabetes.
Now, we're talking about um
uh
oh
um um um we're talking about erectile
dysfunction, low testosterone, adrenal
exhaustion, kidney and liver disease,
death, rhabdomyolysis,
um
fibromyalgia, muscle pain of all kinds,
Alzheimer's disease.
And of course, Alzheimer's disease is a
physician-caused disease. Alzheimer's
disease is again a physician-caused
disease. Alzheimer's disease is a going
away of the myelin, the white matter of
the brain, the insulation material of
the brain
that makes up 75% of brain weight. And
this this myelin the
the insulation material of the brain,
the white matter of the brain that makes
up 75% of brain weight is 100% you got
it, cholesterol.
So, you're going on a
cholesterol-restricted diet, you're
eating egg white omelets instead of
whole egg omelets. You're eating uh egg
beaters instead of eggs, you're eating
boneless, skinless chicken breast
instead of regular chicken. You're
eating um margins and oils instead of
butter and cream and lard, and then
you're eating tofu instead of red meat.
Um and then you're taking statin drugs
to lower your cholesterol.
Well, Alzheimer's disease didn't occur
42 years ago even by another name.
Today, it's number four killer of adults
over age of 65.
Now, by getting on a supplement program
and living on high mineralized food,
okay, we we actually have a study that
came out in 2004 which shows very
clearly
you can reduce your risk of Alzheimer's
disease
by 78 to 80%
Now, that's just with a couple of
vitamins added to a
diet that's that's locally grown on a
highly mineralized soil.
Well, what if you take all 90 essential
nutrients? It'd probably be better than
78%.
What if you eat six eggs a day instead
of none?
It'd certainly be better than 78%. What
if you four to six eggs a day, take all
90 essential nutrients, stay away from
the bad stuff,
and then you uh
uh throw in oh, maybe some uh high
mineralized food. Uh well, the odds of
you getting Alzheimer's disease would
then be
um
what? 100%. You you wouldn't get it.
Okay, remember it didn't exist by
another name before 42 years ago.
So, I urge everybody to get a hold of
that book Hell's Kitchen. Get a hold of
the book Hell's Kitchen. The subtitle is
the cause, prevention, and cure of
obesity, type 2 diabetes, and the
metabolic syndrome, which is insulin
resistance, which is obesity and
cardiovascular disease.
And so, what I want you to do is take
again
um
and I take two Healthy Start Packs a
month myself. I weigh 160, and so I take
um two Healthy Start Packs a month, one
for those during the breakfast and
dinner.
I take um three D-Stress Capsules twice
a day. That's to ward off um what's it
called? Korsakoff's syndrome which looks
like Alzheimer's disease, but is
reversible in a week if you have it just
by supplementing properly with the one
vitamin. And then Wernicke-Korsakoff's,
which is Korsakoff's syndrome and the
deficiency of that one vitamin, but it
also has MS multiple sclerosis, so I
throw in our selenium to support remote
maintenance repair of the brain and help
with the antioxidant power to to uh
resolve some of the lesions in there.
And then in case it is Alzheimer's
disease, I throw in four
of the
Smart Effects three times a day.
Uh that's a
DHAs and EPAs which are the raw
materials for your brain to make
neurotransmitters particularly for
memory and cognition and all that kind
of stuff.
Ultimate Daily Tablets, three of those
twice a day just in case it's vascular
dementia or prevent vascular dementia,
prevent coronary artery disease, prevent
kidney failure. Cuz kidney failure is
not really the kidney, it has to do with
plugging of the arteries in the kidney.
And so, these are things you can do. And
remember, I have not been to a doctor
with me being the patient for 65 years.
For the last 65 years. Never been sick.
Never been on prescription drugs. Now,
if everybody was like me
in America,
let's just talk about America for the
moment. If everybody was like me and
they didn't go to a doctor but once in
65 years,
the medical system would be real humble.
They'd be like the old
Maytag repairman
sitting in a chair depressed throwing
playing cards into a hat because they
have no business because
the Maytag washer and dryer are
constructed so well
they don't need
maintenance men.
But if you take care of yourself with
the 90 essential nutrients, stay away
from the bad stuff, the odds of you
needing a doctor is zero. Uh